what happened
internally when you started speaking up
about this because you started to ask
questions didn't you I did um I started
asking questions often and it got to the
point where I even was having
conversations one-on-one with the doctor
saying I we are harming children we are
doing this uh what would they say
so it's interesting because I I only
recently read the Hannah Barnes book
about the Tavistock and I was it was
almost the exact same response which I
was told my tone was wrong that I was I
shouldn't be directly challenging
doctors and team meetings that I was out
of my Lane that I was
um it was almost identical what happened
at Tavistock
um and the way that I was kind of
treated was I was the annoying squeaky
wheel oh we know Jamie's gonna have
another issue and it got to the point in
the center where
there was a an actual directive
that we were no longer allowed to use
the phrase I have concerns about a
patient
and in medicine
that should scare
anyone because
because if your surgeon comes in and the
nurse thinks that they're drunk
sure as hell that nurse should be able
to say I have concerns about this
patient right now and we need to stop we
need medicine needs people who are
empowered by their Medical Institution
to speak up nurses social workers case
managers you think someone was given the
wrong dose you think they're going to
cut off the wrong limb like you have to
have all of these layers in medicine
have to have people who are empowered
and encouraged to stand up and instead
it was routinely be quiet stop you're
wrong be quiet stop and it got to the
point finally where we were told get on
board or get out and that was
that was the final you say we were the
other people at the center who agreed
with you
we didn't always agree for the same
reasons but there were a few other
people who who agreed okay and you want
the same concerns
yeah and you mentioned speaking directly
one-on-one with doctors so if you come
to a doctor in that sort of clinic and
you would say I think we're harming
these children
what did other than shut up and and stop
raising it did they did they have any
counter arguments or any explanation for
why what they were doing what they were
doing
um
sometimes it would be well what do you
want me to do instead
come up with a different solution then
and I think part of that is that the
whole model of care is so
upside down right now that
it's like every that they're that the
doctors are even just a cog in the
spinning machine and they're like the
only way I know how to spin is this way
like you're telling me we're hurting
people but they would be like what how
do I do differently
because then it would have to stop the
it was almost like for them to actually
stop and think would have to stop the
whole mechanism the whole machine would
have to stop because
it's not just their portion it's the
therapist portion it's the parents
portion it's the kids themselves it's
the hospital it's like all this whole
machine
is spinning and and they were like what
it what do I do and I guess in some ways
I just got to the point where I was like
you know this whole machine just has to
stop right now because
the way that it's going is just it's not
it sort of sounds what you're describing
is like a little bit like a conveyor
belt where it's like yeah right and then
you're going up to one person at one
point and you're going well don't put
this bit in and they're going well
there's a whole machine here there's a
whole conveyor belt you know this is my
job I give hormones or I do this or I do
that right yes exactly this is what they
call their affirmative model where
essentially the moment a kid says I'm
dysphoric from that point on they're
just on the conveyor belt and there's no
getting off unless as long as a kid
right as long as the kid is saying I
want that is the end then that's what
the kid's gonna get
and you said upside down and that really
is upside down because as we talked
about earlier a child cannot really
consent but they are driving this whole
thing is what you're telling us oh that
the language even in some of the
activist groups is that you're supposed
to be child led the child's supposed to
be leading this and here's the thing
about kids
who think that they're the ones who are
supposed to make the decision are
actually in more distress and are in
more pain
because they feel like
there's no grown-ups in the room who are
in charge and as a parent I know for my
own kids they do better in life when I
can say things to them like hey
this is not your decision we're the
grown-ups we've got this handled we know
what we're doing you can go be a kid do
not worry about these things and as they
get older you maybe add a little bit
more like no at Disneyland you cannot
buy the whole Toy Store because
grown-ups only have this much money and
you slowly start giving them some senses
of choice but no a 14 year old does not
want to think that they have to make the
decision for what the whole rest of
their life is for their fertility and
for their medical care
foreign